hello everybody hope they are good this
is a quick update about Bitcoin you can
see that yesterday what they did was to
fill more than the 50 of the week in
fact they almost failed the entire week
but they left around
20 different so the week is pretty much
done for me because you know I think at
least they filter around 95 of it so the
cookies pretty much now done
now does this mean that this prediction
is still gonna play out well we have to
still be cautious because if you notice
what Bitcoin is doing here the structure
is still making lower highs and lower
lows check this out
that's your low now you have here a
lower high a lower low lower high lower
low lower high lower low
and now let's see what it does so at
least it has to break above this on here
okay otherwise it's gonna do a new lower
high I'm going to see a new lower low
all right I hope that's clear so what we
want to see is that Bitcoin breaks above
this yellow Mark over here so that's
around the 28 000 sun right that's what
we need to see if we see something like
this
break above it some kind of sideways
moves then you know it's looking good
for continuation to the upside and if
you notice here you have a liquidity
pool in this Zone
okay and you also have a smaller
liquidity pool here
so this is what I'm looking at now okay
so in my case what I did yesterday was
to wait for some kind of reversal and I
found mine in this Scandal it's a 8 PM
UTC time this is a bullish engulfing
candle and this is telling me that there
is momentum to the upside so what I was
shooting here was for some kind of
retrace towards this one here
because you can see that here there is a
bit of Confluence the price between
these two candle bodies price price
might come to the zone and I was looking
at it and that's around 27 470 that's
what I opened my long uh now you know
I'm sitting with my trade open uh it's
not much to be honest it's not a big
position set compared to other trades
because as I told you we haven't broken
these batteries structure so
um my stop loss is quite tight I'm
waiting to see if something like this
happens and if I see something like this
and we break
Above This previous High then I'm going
to add to my position here targeting
these two liquidity pools so that's what
I'm keeping an eye on now also very
important this one here that I'm telling
you what this this zero line if you
notice that's around 27 900 or or 28
000. now if you go to the Daily time
frame you want to notice that sorry the
wanna notice that this one is also the
58 the 50 EMA okay let me remove this
because there is a lot of things going
on there so you can see it better
this worries me to be honest because you
can see that the 50ma was or support for
six times you know okay as you can see
one two three four five six times so
this is this support for six times and
yesterday we lost it we closed a daily
candle below it now could this be some
kind of fake out yes it could you know
we have CPI data tomorrow I think that
the market might in a way I think it's
probably gonna wait until CPA half 12
tomorrow on Wednesday so we might see
some kind of consolidation today not
much going on um tomorrow let's see if
we see something like this
you know between this daily candle and
tomorrow's daily candle some kind of a
push-up okay and then we are again back
above it then you want to see some kind
of retest support and then this is what
you can be again comfortable with your
lungs all right
um
now in the other hand what I wouldn't
like to see it's something like this in
my end it is the Fifth Harmony you know
the continuation and you see
today or tomorrow
some kind of test of pre-test of
resistance
and then you're telling me here that
this support has flipped into resistance
and then we are going to go lower
authoriously my target I see that the
next Target would be the Zone over here
okay all right let me let me change the
color of this let me the white
okay this would be the next Zone that
you know it's been quite quite extra
support in this Zone and then we
continue higher so that's around twenty
six thousand five hundred if we lose
this area then we're gonna go to the
next one that is 25 300 and this one is
quite interesting because you can see
that there was a sell-off here when we
came to this Zone then we came back to
to this area here another sell-off and
we haven't tested it as support yet okay
so that's quite interesting so
um now I've been telling you this if
this happens okay if we lost the 50ma
we've done that now we test it as
resistance and we continue going lower
maybe to 25k
is it still high because you can check
now if you go to the Bitcoin dominant
chart
it's still holding up here okay so if it
holds up in this Zone let me go to the
Daily time frame sorry to the weekly
time frame
if it holds in this Zone while Bitcoin
is going down then outside is still
gonna bleed a lot okay so this is why
pretty much everything you have to keep
in mind if you get to the dollar Index
uh you can see that it's pumping all
right so it's been testing this low for
quite some time this is the weekly time
frame remember if we go to the four hour
time frame
all right you can see that it's been
around this zone for how long is this
um almost a month to be honest and now
it seems that it wants to go high again
so after before in the dollar Index I
can't be bearish until we break below
this low so as long as we are above this
low we've seen also here a sweep of the
lows you can see here
let me show you
do you see so uh that's some kind of
deviation so as long as we don't break
below it I think the valarines can go
higher
because there is a lot of room Mr here
you can see it can go to 103 why not and
if that happens then Bitcoin is going to
continue going lower now this MP let's
check this MP this MP is quite
interesting chart because you know we've
been saying that it's just it's kind of
a sideways move after this push
uh from the lows you can see it was
quite a good push and is doing some kind
of sideways quite similar to what
happened here so let's see how this
develop
um the SMP at the moment while the
market has been driven by data and we
have again CPI tomorrow
um so that could move the market let's
see how the restaurants are again I
don't think today we're gonna see much
going on today should be quite a chill
day and tomorrow in the New York session
that it will be a lot of volatility and
I'll be covering that tomorrow
and probably post a video
um earlier tomorrow so so you can you
can be prepared for any scenario that
might happen and that's pretty much
everything guys so you know be careful
with Bitcoin
um don't be opening sure to or or Longs
here because I don't think that this is
like a zone for anybody to trade only if
you already have some open positions
like my case
um again with a stop loss because you
know it's very likely that price come
back comes back to that to that zone
um and I enter breaking even okay that's
pretty much look Market this one in your
charts are around 27 900 you need to see
a breakup above that level and also in
the daily time frame you would like to
see that Bitcoin goes again above the 50
EMA so that's pretty much everything
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon